done it is of course the
last day of early voting here in nevada
with election day
just days away now even as early voting
winds down
both the trump and biden campaigns still
kicking things into high gear
orco mana joining us from the east las
vegas community center
where a voting celebration is taking
place orco
yeah brian well both campaigns say it's
extremely important to vote in this
election
because it is so crucial and that
includes the latino community
and that's why they're having a fiesta
here with music and food to celebrate
those folks who are voting early
now as you mentioned today is the last
day of early voting in nevada
and our state has seen impressive
turnout over the past two
weeks the latest numbers from the
secretary of state's office showed that
as of this afternoon
more than 1 million nevadans have
already cast their ballots
either by mail or in-person early voting
and there are still folks who are
expected to vote early through this
evening
for perspective the total number of
votes cast in 2016
was 1.1 million clark county is
reporting more than 342 000 in-person
early votes but that doesn't include
today's numbers
still both campaigns know their work
isn't over i spoke one-on-one with biden
surrogate senator bernie sanders
as well as the trump victory team to get
their final pitch to voters
if you believe in honesty
if you believe that a president is not
above the law if you believe that we
need
scientific guidelines to help us deal
with this pandemic and to deal with
climate change
then i think the choice is pretty clear
nevadans aren't looking to go back to
the uh the days of the obama biden
recession
they know that this president is going
to get this economy roaring again and
back better than it was
and they know exactly what's at stake
the latest new york times poll shows
biden six points ahead of president
trump here in nevada but we are still
considered a battleground state so
every vote counts so again the main
message from everyone is just go out and
vote
in person early voting will wrap up at
about eight o'clock tonight
at the different in-person locations
across the valley and there will also be
more than
100 in-person polling sites on election
day which is just four days away
this upcoming tuesday reporting live in
east las vegas tonight orco mana 8 news
now